Hey everyone, Trace here for DNews answering a long-held question in a lot of people's minds.
What's the difference between a hurricane and a typhoon?
We hear both words a lot.
They're both storms that get names.
The super typhoon hitting Asia right now is named Haiyan or Yolanda, by the way.
The main difference between a hurricane and a typhoon,...
...believe it or not, is simply where the storm occurs.
According to NOAA, hurricanes form in the Northern Atlantic,...
...Northeastern Pacific and South Pacific.
Typhoons form in the Northwestern Pacific specifically.
There are also cyclones, I forgot all about them,...
...which form in the Southwest Pacific Ocean and the Indian Ocean.
Science likes naming things and they're very thorough.
Basically, there are three names for the same big spinny storms.
And one cool fact, the word "hurricane" comes from the name of one of the Mayan gods,...
...Huracan, who helped create the world, no big deal.
Other than location, is there anything unique about each type of storm?
Not really.
All three storms share humble beginnings as tropical storms.
Each begin over warm oceans where there are high levels of air moisture and wind.
If the right conditions persist, then these spinning storms will grow.
And when they reach sustained internal wind speeds of 74 miles an hour,...
...they can bring torrential rain, flooding and all the other hallmarks of a big storm like that.
The location of the typhoon, cyclone or hurricane determines the direction it spins.
Just being a typhoon doesn't mean it will spin in a specific direction.
Same with a hurricane.
Storms can spin either way.
All storms forming in the Northern Hemisphere spin counterclockwise,...
...while those forming in the Southern Hemisphere spin clockwise.
Easy peasy.